hey let's go bros my name as a poet ha
ha I don't remember ending the last
episode here
oh yeah the [ __ ] cage thing okay fine
you know what fine let's just do this
real quick we know what's gonna happen
I'm gonna take a nap see it's you in a
second Luke Edie roti Oh
okay we are back now wait wait a minute
this isn't that now we're not quite back
yet sorry
whoa what no way I found you through the
man - what a boy hey how you been boots
I missed you do you got any food Jesus
Christ just get me out of the cage
please it's so bored this part was so
boring yes I haven't absolutely no
patience whatsoever I'm so sorry trick
ow oh that's so cute
it's cuddling a cage can you help me a
please you got a plan what are you doing
smelling the grass I need you to help me
do something damn it
thank you so much wow that really helps
that really changes everything is this
smelling around where are you you nearly
drowned me by the way just do something
there we go
oh it's so cute oh my god mr. two men
but I need you to get me out of this
cage ASAP it's taking way too long
alright if you push me up here
that'd be great can you do that BuChE
BuChE me give it a little push give it a
little nut bear hey that's so cool we
did it thank you
ah oh my [ __ ] head I should put on
this helmet that's inside here oh okay
here we go oh boy this should be scary
careful now careful [ __ ] oh my god
alright will it spin Gary oh my god ah
I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine don't you
worry can I get out of here now oh no
[ __ ]
this is not going great I am aware but
I'm trying my [ __ ] best here okay
damn hey Treecko I need your help buddy
warthog you win you need me there it is
look at this we are really trying to
kill ourselves change sexes what's your
strategy here dude keep rolling rolling
rolling rolling what Wow
[ __ ] all the way that we went up oh boy
we do not want to fall down the stairs
now
bad news is waiting down the stairs did
you really ought to just put on that
broken hand there we go suicide tricky
are you here
I'm like oh God Oh God bad idea holy
[ __ ] that's awesome
Oh oh I get it
that's so cool I just need to make our
way to the other one that's it sear
steer now forward ship steer steer steer
my dear there it is we did it now we
should fly up or that or that
or that I was just about to I'm free are
you back pounds I missed dude I missed
you too that was a mean Treecko and I
climbed it oh my god are we getting
attacked I miss I miss humane oh he's so
cute
you were too cozy - Nick - oh he's
hungry let's try to see if we can make
him go to sleep barbeque I know you're
tired me I know you've been through a
lot looking for me and I appreciate that
so now why don't you take a little nap
and I'll go and find you a snake you
want a little red ball as well so you
can feel a little better
oh that's right okay maybe we can take
the elevator back the other one you know
what I mean
yeah that's things I could say okay
let's go
I don't know how this qualifies as an
elevator oh it's going down okay a down
evader am i right I'm here all night do
we make great jokes there is okay so I
know there's a barrel there's one behind
me here it's really annoying I don't
know how to get past it maybe it's some
way around I don't know how the helmet
the game is tipping oh that's a good
possible thank you for revealing the
whole puzzle for me you're a [ __ ]
idiot Pierce you needed to get that
[ __ ] hear me I can't tell you because
I'm a [ __ ] catfish salmon down fish
shut up here we go of course thank you
game here we go
shut up that's why we went all the way
for the helmet inside helmet inside
helmet inside with the bit above the end
the helmet inside that's not the legs ok
great
- today ok alright [ __ ] you
not you of course the other one ok see I
knew where it was at least that's not a
bad quality to know unlimited pass [ __ ]
[ __ ] Shah Baba
ok it's ok I've been trained oh my god
[ __ ] ok alright what you gonna do huh
she's gonna [ __ ] do huh it's gonna
[ __ ] do huh
why don't you come here watch me [ __ ]
a [ __ ] off [ __ ] I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] keg you got a problem with kegs
got a problem with me that's [ __ ] hurry
up hurry up
nailed it you nailed you nail that
you're [ __ ] idiot don't touch me
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you want a hug
you better hug someone else
holy spread right here for ya
oh really oh that's real nice
there was a trick ah [ __ ]
panic got him
no don't [ __ ] touch me
you don't [ __ ] touch me oh it's using
me Mia Jitsu [ __ ]
[ __ ] not to anything but the out how
funny he'll better throw it throw it
throw it up spit downs jab laugh it up
good job
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you weren't such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh how about that it
didn't [ __ ] work how about that I
said be cool you're funny that name and
then hope buddy you need it wait a
minute can I just walk up with it buddy
feet down jab laughs what the [ __ ] god
damn it
[Music]
bye-bye [ __ ] well well well look who
finally made out huh
oh my god it's a - Nick did you know I
love snakes
oh my god it's at oh it's Pringles
there you go you got it take the
Pringles take the trinkles take it thank
you
take the Pringles thank the Pringles
Thanks ah we're dead if you ate the
Pringles now let's go can we go can we
go now I thought it was weird cuz this
place is so cool designed the fact that
we stayed so little timing here was kind
of a shame this is pretty cave if you
look at it if you appreciate it's all
right our textual Beauty he really
doesn't listen to me uh I don't know
what to do about it
did your horns grow are you getting more
horny I'm 12
there we go nice and then just one more
jump tricky truth
James just Christ that [ __ ] name Joe
trick out your left horn is bigger than
your right one that's a bit awkward shut
up shut your [ __ ] mouth
all right where do we where where is
this going now Oh
[Music]
all right you're the mini jump fine you
know what fine where could I go now
pouch I don't know
hey how about up wherever okay yes dog
time oh oh my god that was a little
higher than that though
Hey look at that we made it back no
wonder he took ages for you to find me
Jesus bro now that other Treecko went
through that wall it was very cool he
did it very elegantly gotta find him
I'm gonna skin him and then we're gonna
sleep in his skin
okay you want to clean yourself a little
bit no that's fine I've got plenty of oh
Jesus it will be back soon
oh he's saying the other thing good boy
do that jump oh yeah oh oh go go chica
he says you [ __ ] crate and what am I
looking at what the hell I'm Alex
another one another one do it man
get up there boy yeah we're doing great
dude we got such good project progress
there I think I recognize where we are
oh my feet just broke bow for them let's
have a look outside this is already oh
my god
look at that whoa are we like high up
now this is like winter each race is
just alike
what are you doing dude I'm expecting
the view you're being an ass what are
you saying you need an aspirin it's such
a loving creature how can you use it for
war that would be like having a little
Pomeranian out in the battle with full
armor and shields
I missed it too buddy I missed you too
but it's time for us to progress in this
game and progress will be made only by
me playing it so [ __ ] you and your
cuddles I can go here by myself I'm
going to die am i oh god oh god I'm
going to die there we go
what are you are doing there poets don't
worry about it
I have a deep epic voicemail which means
I can climb much better that's right you
I can see your tiny little balls again
shut up I can smell them - look at this
jump look at that jump huh
and I am a dead person I am the worst
player at this game I'd realize now you
if you're watching you're watching the
words let's play ever of this game
that's awesome
don't you feel special there we go okay
whoo nice okay all right we are making
our way downtown walking fast faces I'm
passing my home BAM you're single you
should do that part staring blankly on
Shriekers ass my way making my way
through that finding and now I wonder
when watching Beauty pass shady let's
play I could be doing clearly anything
else
oh there's many are there let players
out there so why am I watching this
tonight good one here we go
I think I should have been the voice
acting for the little boy I think it's
much better shut up [ __ ] off pounds okay
then all right just listen to this huh
pretty good huh yeah I did I buy cheese
would you would you much rather hear
that oh well I guess suppose you are in
the way cheat chacha-ji truth I need
some ad lib [ __ ] there smells like Edgar
took a [ __ ] oh look at this
this is very nice I really like this
plus if you got rid of the Treecko
let's see if we can open the gate for
him I am sure there must be a gate here
some a lover
Hey look who it is I misspelled I messed
put oh my god there you are
I wasn't I wasn't missing it
there you go buddy follow me welcome in
this is my new house if you buy enough
Lambo so you couldn't combine them into
this house oh no it's a bad area this is
a mean part where he goes crazy stay
there
Eddie or stay there I'm going for it
though Oh No
why did I go for it [ __ ] don't touch me
I'm hoping Nikki go kill myself
I hate these guys with a [ __ ] passion
I hope y'all [ __ ] dad you remind me
of someone really annoying like me
that's probably why I don't like you
don't what I say huh what I say what the
[ __ ] just happened
no no not evil trick Oh again
I don't want evil tree cow shake it up
shake it off
Treecko but imma eat blood I must eat
your soul god damn it that's just what
happens it's me you're [ __ ] dead
you're [ __ ] dead who's gonna bust you
around now huh no drink oh oh well if
you know how to fight properly I'd be
dead by now but clearly you suck I just
[ __ ] die well that's a little awkward
what happens now does it reset or they
just this thing again where it shows us
the past it seems like this story behind
setting maybe I hope because I'm very
clear there's us ah
we woke up by a butterfly we don't have
the shitty tattoos well
cuz that Treecko flying oh my god that'd
be cool if his wings will grow out as
well wow that would be the ultimate dad
would be the ultimate this is our home
it's very cool
Treecko just maybe he attacked us
he has their big wings that's [ __ ]
awesome
that is creepy as hell
children why don't you come and play
with me children
we're having a bad
what what what does that mean
Oh Treecko you blew it gotta wash your
feathers dude that is strange
that is very interesting oh okay uh-huh
hey how you doing mama just having a
little snack all right come on I was
just I loved Pringles you got a problem
so he's being controlled right
that's so [ __ ] cool I love this movie
I want a full feature film dude I just
ate the kid what do you want it's just
one snack the question is who put the
armor on clearly these guys technology
is not very advanced
he does it fly away at any moment no
nice I mean not nice but I mean evil I
don't know who I'm rooting for
so maybe when he pooped his out we got
the tattoos you know that would make
sense in a world where treecko's are
real natural Ottoman is all Rabia be
among the chosen one
are we the chosen one perhaps I mean
obviously humans put armors on him but
why and how and what
[Music]
so he flew flew as far away to some
ancient temple
with all this advanced technology
that's so [ __ ] cool if we can fly
with him in the end I will be very happy
very very satisfied I wouldn't be myself
how we just bang
this is the first real cutscene that we
got so far I mean we had a few but this
is the first longer one it's so cool I
wish we had more
that's the thing that control
what a weird city but we were struck by
lightning well you need a lightning rod
Chico it's your metal piece flying in
the area with you
and that's how the game started no
[ __ ] way
that's how the game started huh Oh
favorite Rika
[Music]
wait what so they retreat
the soldiers
who controls the soldiers
and they put us there they placed us
there that's strange that's even more
strange why would they do that you know
and where do we come into place they
chained us up
probably because they couldn't control
isn't well that what that is a barf that
is disgusting
don't you just hate when you eat little
boys and bark them up I hate when that
happens
so we came from his mouth and added that
ooze on okay a little strange but hey I
can dig it
let's go to the light sorry I ate your
kid hope you don't mind and we have more
tattoos honest now don't we every time
he eats okay three cuz we saw it it was
so secluded oh my god I must've been
gigantic that
[Music]
hey Treecko could you stop [ __ ]
eating me
so we're an ancient creature from the
ancient civilization but why did it
because he was clearly told to go and
retrieve the boy there's something more
- there's something else to this
[Music]
oh this is so sad
[Music]
[Music]
how's the game and nothing else I want
to know more about this ancient
civilization
Thanks hahahaha facedown sure looks dead
[Music]
then who would tell the story sorry I'm
using like a secure
anyway cuz I'm in the water
you better not just drop in haha great
now we're drowning hey it work thanks
Treecko oh he's so happy
thanks Sookie 3
I think you can cut over nails like this
oh I'm so happy happy happy happy I
suppose it makes sense for me to keep
going a little bit like what do you say
while you're still listening have you
been tabbed out doing other [ __ ] what
that oh I'm kidding of course a little
joke let's not go back here what happens
if we go back oh you think you'll still
go crazy
a Treecko you're gonna lose it if you go
here buddy eat me again that may make me
look real ow
my everything well I mean it seemed fine
last time the question is how do we get
past this point surely they must feel I
don't want last time I ate you it tastes
like [ __ ] I don't know how to tell and
get me up there that would begin I'll be
excellent if you could do that don't
hurt yourself now ball
just put me up a love okay that's all I
need nice jump there buddy jump up jump
up there we go now don't be scared
trigger by a bit oh he's gone hahaha hey
look at that we can walk down ladders
now I know how do I finally learn how to
do it you hold X which is weird because
you press actually it's not that weird I
just rally for you oh ow Hey look at
that I found a lever if I could only
reach it far away
these tattoos that I have on my body
represents that I've been eating three
times it's pretty cool though I mean we
definitely have more tattoos on it I
wonder if we gonna be covered by the end
of it I mean we clearly are already I
wonder if anyone's gonna be lame enough
to get these tattoos I mean actually
they're kind of cool now that I look
closer kind of looks like someone's
wrote on you with pain or some [ __ ] I
don't ok whatever you have here
minecraft [ __ ] this way then shake oh
okay I'll be right back [ __ ] out nope
nothing here maybe a way to control
these what are you doing you're not a
cat
this has just oh my god I sighs butthole
this has to stop Treecko could you break
this door open
oh I see there you go that's why he
peeps is heading come on boy
but I'm too fat you said it yourself no
no no no you're not
you look great by the way you look so
good that's it
that's my boy okay you said I'm skinny
here I come oh geez says hey how skinny
am I you're so skinny just keep on a
little further but I'm too okay
okay right now I'm so skinny Here I am
this is so creepy and weird okay
all right I did it thanks Treecko for
nothing but you said I wish Kenny he
could easily knock these over I don't
know man
they usually just [ __ ] slam these
door open let me spank that ass smack
I'm stuck okay this way clearly you can
fit in here right without a problem
right I don't know what I'm doing
that seems to be the case a lot a lot of
times when I played this game
um Harmon not everyone is a cat dogfish
snake you discriminate against our
nation that does not look normal over
there
look at him I'm skinny I'm skinning I
well fit I'm skinny damn it [ __ ] Oh
skinny I'm skinny
that looks terrifying look at that
without oh my god there's no way you can
fit dude I am the chosen skinny one
looks like he's in pain it looks like
it's coming from out of the ground what
do I do
enjoy the gate [ __ ] what do I do
No
what another one of these did we die
what happened
we'll find out in the next episode leave
a like if you enjoyed check out the next
episode here and I'll see you there's
two more I'm sorry I got a I know it got
a little confusing okay I'm sorry I am
sorry but it means we have more stuff to
watch so it's a good it's a good thing
don't you I thank you so much for
watching with me today we had fun and as
always stay awesome price
[Music]